you know I want to ask you about
somebody who has a reputation of being a
sweetheart that people love this guy
uh just a very kind loving personality
what are your thoughts on Dick Cheney
[Laughter]
I liked vice president Cheney
um he was a curmudgeon a tough guy
um
but you know what people don't
understand about my job at the White
House is I worked for President Bush I
was Bush's spokesman and Bush was the
boss
training was a vice president The
Outsiders thought Cheney's in control
training is in charge which Bush always
could care less about because again the
guy's a confident guy he have a thick
skin and that criticism was so wrong
that it never bothered Bush so I looked
at the vice president as one of many
good advisors that bush had whispering
in his ear sometimes he was a little too
truculent
um you know I think with the CIA what
does truculent mean across Layman's uh
a little too uh tough argumentative
curmudgeon
um
personalities professionally is a little
truculent
um but he did it because he believed has
nothing to do with money and nothing to
do with Halliburton it was because he
believed you don't believe that you
don't believe you need the money no
fully no first of all he severed his
ties to Halliburton so literally how
could he make a profit off of anything
that he did because Halliburton did
severed ties he was no longer with them
um so whatever money Halliburton made or
lost was immaterial to the vice
president
umholder
I think he had to divest I'm sure
everybody I'm president's and vice
presidents I think are not allowed to
have any stock or mutual funds
um
but presidents are not allowed to have
yeah I think they all divest or it's
blind Trust
it's probably a time man it's probably
about I trust yeah it's a blind trust
um
but anyway to the point he was an audio
log and and a very big believer in the
old neocon muscular foreign policy and
that he was very much on the side to get
rid of Saddam
um but the CIA would tell you is if
there was any interference they ever got
from the White House it was not from
President Bush not from President Bush's
people it was the vice president and the
vice president's people who put pressure
on the CIA to conclude that there were
ties between Saddam and Al Qaeda
that's an angle that the vice president
particularly thought was true and he
really wanted the CIA to run that down
President Bush and see I would tell you
this always said to the CIA just tell me
what you know
and he gave him no pressure one way or
another he said just tell me what you
know Ari for every 10 times you spoke to
President Bush how many times did you
talked to Dick Cheney
well Cheney would be in a lot of the
meetings
so Cheney would be sitting there but as
anybody from the White House will tell
you Cheney didn't talk much Bush did the
talking Bush's advisors did the talking
and then Cheney would get together with
bush once a week for their private lunch
and that's when Cheney would say to Bush
here's what I think that was the vice
president's opportunity then to
influence the president which he did
but in the meetings in all these
different meetings
Cheney didn't talk much did did I guess
what was their relationship meaning
Cheney's how many years older than
George W bush yeah but that didn't
matter dozen 20 years so it's got I mean
well a little bit maybe like why maybe
seniority wisdom I I kind of that means
Joe Biden knows more than anybody else
well yeah that's a whole nother
conversation but
the knock on Cheney was that he was this
evil doer running the show would you
agree to that at least the knock on it
yeah oh and I dealt with that all the
time before 9 11 especially I mean the
knock on the Bush Administration was
Cheney's in charge right it was always
nonsense what complete nonsense right
there there's there's the reality then
there's Optics yeah like but the Press
always has to have something to chew on
and so that's what they chewed on which
was a meaningless thing to chew on got
it but you did say that he was the one
that kind of wanted the CIA to chase
down the the story about Al Qaeda Al
Qaeda yeah I think the CIA would tell
you that so what does that mean exactly
he kind of wanted to invade Iraq oh is
that what that means Cheney definitely
wanted to depose Saddam oh he thought it
would promote world peace and would be
in America's interest it wasn't Cheney's
decision though it was Bush's decision
and how how much part of
how much a part of Bush's decision
was influenced by the fact that his
father went to war in Iraq zero uh
Desert Storm Schwarzkopf and he didn't
get the job done quote unquote
you don't think that played a little
part of of going out put yourself in
George Bush's shoes America's been
attacked September 11th takes place yeah
CIA says on September 11th after the
attack it's not a question of if it's a
question of when there will be a second
wave there will be a second wave
and that starts to create all the
infrastructure and the decisions that
bush starts to make about how to fortify
America and never let us be hit again
which is entire mentality as we got hit
once I will never let this country be
hit again
Saddam has zero nothing to do with
September 11th and I said that
repeatedly from the podium right that's
why we invaded Afghanistan not Iraq
first correct but again put yourself in
Bush's shoes so Saddam had nothing to do
with 9 11.
but you are told there will be a second
wave and then you're told Saddam
definitely has wmd
and Bush's my mindset is I will never
let this country be attacked again so
you can decide all right he's got
biological and chemical weapons and
there's nothing America can do about it
we'll just have to hope he never uses
them or
I believe in the doctrine of preemption
I'm going to take Saddam out because he
is wmd
and that is the decision that George
Bush ultimately made that people will
argue about for decades now whether it
was right or wrong and I repeatedly have
that said now it was based on false
premises that he had wmd when he did not
so what all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valutamin it says future looks bright
here future looks bright here we got
them in white we got them in Black we
got them in red our black on black sold
out these are about to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he bought three
then when those three people wore it in
the office they had to order 58 of them
because people wanted the future looks
bright hat especially during times like
this because ain't nobody's saying
future look spread toward your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
foreign
[Music]